[Music]
can you tell me about that the Carter
push party how was it and the pictures
look magnificent that was excellent and
we had so much fun yeah yeah nice and
intimate and just a lot of fun
Tina's style that so everything you saw
she created that well that's what I want
to ask you because so much of it from
way back has been your style so how much
of your daughter style because now they
are a style icons but how much of it
came from you I think a lot came from
for me but also just like a shower
that's her vision and I just helped make
it come alive you know all of my girls
just have such great style and I'm just
so proud but I'm sure they got a little
bit from their mommy you know they got a
lot from her because of the fact that
you know Tina has always been
unrelenting about her vision and the one
thing that they got is to be unrelenting
about their vision you don't I mean they
will never let their vision or their
concepts or ideas be thwarted by someone
else these are the twins that the world
is waiting for and can you give us any
update no no I have a suggestion okay be
patient that is resonation cause it's
gonna be an amazing amazing thing yeah
how is beyonce doing good she's great
doing great she's just ready to see her
face all right well the world is waiting
for the announcement